- I've been through the
toughest times with my family,
but I'm still standing.
It was kind of tough
knowin' that sometimes
I would work so hard than everybody else,
and I wasn't seein', I wasn't
reapin' the benefits of it,
and I wasn't...
I means people just always say that,
"It's cool, you're top
three, that's cool."
And a lot of people got on
me for cryin' on national TV,
but when you want somethin'
that bad, it's just like,
I didn't care.
You know, we talk about the end result,
if it's not where it should
be, then it's a failure.
When something good happens
to you, I don't know
about you guys, but I tend to look back
to what brought me here.
- He's an American
professional basketball player
for the Oklahoma City Thunder of the NBA.
- He's won an NBA
Most-Valuable Player award,
four NBA scoring titles, and
the Rookie of the Year award.
- He's been selected to six all-NBA teams
and seven All-Star teams.
- He's Kevin Durant and here's
my take on his top ten rules
for success.
- I come from a small,
county outside of Washington D.C.,
called P.G. county.
Me, my mom, my brother,
we moved so many different
places growin' up,
and, it felt like a box.
It felt like there was no gettin' out.
I loved basketball so
much, I loved playin' it,
I just never thought I could
make it to college, NBA,
or stand up here today
in front of you guys
and be a NBA MVP.
So many people believed in
me when I didn't believe
in myself.
So many people doubted me
and motivated me every
single day to be who I am.
I failed so many times and got back up.
I've been through the
toughest times with my family.
But, I'm still standin'.
- [Announcer] You continue
to put the ball in his hands.
Durant comin' to the rim.
I'll bring the...
(laughing)
Oh, big ol' tomahawk.
- It was kind of tough
knowin' that sometimes
I would work so hard than everyone else
and I wasn't reapin' the benefits of it.
I wasn't gettin' any better
as quickly as I wanted to,
but I stayed patient, and
that was one big thing for me,
is knowin' when to stay patient,
that everything's going to come around.
And I think that, you know,
with that patience I gained
as a kid, it's helpin'
me in the NBA right now.
For me, it's just, always,
always workin' hard
and always tryin' to get better.
And knowin' I can get better,
knowin' that I'm not there where
I want to be yet, so, I
have a long ways to go.
- [Announcer] Durant scoops
it up off the window,
my goodness!
Oh, the two-time scoring
champ showing you why.
- Kevin, this is your quote,
"I've been second my whole life,
"I was the second best
player in high school,
"second pick in the draft,
"second in the MVP voting three times,
"I came in second in the finals,
I'm tired of being second.
"I'm not going to settle
for that, I'm done with it."
Stand by that?
- Definitely.
I means people just always say that,
"It's cool, you're top three, that's cool.
"It's all right to be a top
three player in the world.
"Millions of people in this world
and you can be the top
three, that's pretty cool."
I mean I'm just tired
of settlin' for that.
Tired of sayin' that, tired of hearin' it.
- [Announcer] Westbrook to
trigger at nine seconds,
got to get it in, it's
in the hands of Durant,
the scoring champ, from the top.
Against Marion, Durant put up jumper,
off the rim and it...
(crowd cheering)
And the Thunder win!
Durant beat 'em again!
- [Announcer] All right let's go.
- [Crowd Member] Let's go alright?
- I work out on the court on
drills, but pick-up is where
I hone my instincts for the game.
- [Announcer] On his knees, up his throat.
(cheering)
- I love bein' around the atmosphere.
I love bein' around basketball players,
I love to hear the people talk trash
to me when I'm out in
the neighborhood playin'.
I love it, that's the best
part of the summer to me.
- [Announcer] The other
way, good rejection
and block by Durant who comes galloping
and Durant taking it down!
Rockin' the rim, goin'
high and comin' down hard!
(cheering)
- But, it's just a matter of me, you know,
continuin' to learn the game and watch
and try to get better each and every day.
And, not being complacent,
and I think that's the biggest thing,
wanted to be great, but, in this game
it's half and half mental and physical,
maybe more mental than physical.
So I got to get my mind
right and be able to handle
a whole season and the
playoffs, to be a good player.
But with me, it's just,
all about progressin'
and knowin' what I need
to work on and work on it.
- [Announcer] 23 points in their open...
What a move by Durant!
And he let's the big doggy,
Collison, with the finish.
- [Announcer] Adamovic
is still feeling that...
- Oh, it was historical.
I think about that run all the time.
Oklahoma City is all about,
first off natural disasters,
and Oklahoma City bombin',
just to put it out there,
to be real, I mean, that's
what the city was known for.
And to win a Western
Conference title Championship
with a group of young guys.
The city's never seen anything like it
and it's somethin'' I'm
always goin' to remember.
- [Reporter] But the
Thunder lost the NBA title
to the Miami Heat and
Lebron James in five games.
Kevin Durant was second again,
and there to console
him was the same person
who made him do push-ups
in the middle of the night,
12 years earlier.
- [Interviewer] Long hug with your Mom,
after you all didn't make it there,
and you hugged her long and hard.
- (sighs) Well, first off,
that was just a thank you.
My mom, she was always there
at the right time, man.
And a lot of people got on
me for cryin' on national TV,
but, when you want somethin' that bad,
it was just like, I didn't care.
- [Announcer] Be hard
pressed to beat 11.(laughs)
I'm tellin' you that's hard
pressed to beat 11. (laughs)
Durant to...
Oh!
K.D.
packin' it.
On McGee.
The All-Top 10.
- You know, in the first
few games of the playoffs
I was just so excited to be a
part of that atmosphere again,
and to be back on that
level, it was just amazin'.
I appreciate every single moment,
I always refer back to me bein' injured
because that was the first
time something got taken away
from me I loved so much,
and it just made me appreciate
every moment, you know.
Because we can easily talk
about the end result of things,
but that whole journey...
We talk about the end result
if it's not where it should be
then it's a failure,
but I look at it like,
look, this is an
important part of my life,
this memory is somethin'
I'm always going to carry,
and it was just great to be a part of,
to be on the court playin'
in that atmosphere again.
- [Announcer] Here we go,
tie game Wally has it,
out front Durant, gets it
to a three for the win!
It's already good!
Kevin Durant, rises, reigns
and drains the 28 footer!
The Sonics win in Atlanta,
you got to love it!
- To always do it for the love,
no matter what it is, and work
hard, it may sound cliche,
but hard work really does
payoff in whatever you're doin'.
That's the motto I use,
if you set small goals
and try to reach them and
that's when big goals start
to come around and, before you know it,
you're goin' to start
risin' the totem pole.
- Durant...
- Goal!
Oh, my goodness, Roy Hibbert
couldn't get there in time
on that.
Durant's, look at that!
You got to be kiddin' me.
- I just try to make it about the team,
make it about my teammates, it's not fair
to the organization and to my
teammates to be distracted.
I have to be the best me I can be,
and, I think, I was proud of how
I was able to stay in the moment,
that's been a struggle for me
as a young player in this league.
So I was stayin' conscious
of bein' in the moment
and I was proud of how I stayed there,
especially throughout the
playoffs and the regular season.
It was just all about worryin' about today
and once tomorrow get there,
I'll worry about that.
That's who I've been the last few years,
just takin' it day by day.
- [Announcer] Achieving cult
status right now in Dallas
after his last two performances.
Durant!
Oh, and a foul!
- [Announcer] Kevin Durant throws it down.
- [Announcer] My goodness,
Kevin Durant says to Brendan Haywood,
"Excuse me, I got an
appointment with the rim."
- The odds were stacked against us,
single parent with two boys,
by the time we were 21 years old,
everybody told us, "We
weren't supposed to be here."
We moved from apartment to apartment,
by ourselves.
One of the best memories
I had, is when we moved
into our first apartment,
no bed, no furniture
and we just all sat in the living room
and just hugged each other,
because, we thought we'd made it.
And when something good happens to you,
I don't know about you guys,
but I tend to look back
to what brought me here.
And you wake me up in
the middle of the night,
in the summertimes,
makin' me run up the hill,
makin' me do push-ups, screamin'
at me from the sidelines
of my games at eight or nine years old.
We wasn't supposed to be here.
You made us believe, you
kept us off the street,
put clothes on our
backs, food on the table.
When you didn't eat, you made sure we ate.
You went to sleep hungry.
You sacrificed for us. (crying)
You're the real MVP.
(applause)
- [Announcer] Here is Durant for the win!
(cheering)
Kevin Durant
has won
at the buzzer!
- [Announcer] What a sensational play
and shot by Kevin Durant!
That's how you win games at the buzzer!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
- We made this video because
Robin Sharma asked us to.
If you'd like us to profile someone else,
leave a message in the comments below.
- I'd also love to know which
of the top 10 rules meant the most to you,
had the biggest impact,
leave in the comments
and we'll join in the discussion.
So thank you guys again for watching,
continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- My game is based upon bein' versatile,
I think, you know, my biggest attribute,
is scorin' the basketball.
I think I find the rim in different ways.
I think I'm a shot maker.
I can play inside and out, I'm
still workin' on both parts
of my game, I'm far
from where I want to be.
But, with my length and my
size, I can play inside and out.
I think about the future a lot,
the steps I have to take
now for us to, maybe,
be a championship team.
Or, what it's goin' to look like for me
in three or four years, what I'm be doin',
or where I'm be at.
What team I'm play for.
I never thought I'd be
able to impact people,
the way I have so far.
I take pride in that.
I'm just a regular guy,
I play ball on TV sometimes.
And knowin' I can give
'em hope and inspire 'em,
has been somethin' that's
been like a dream come true.
- [Player] One, two, three!
- [Crowd] Strong and kind!